jacques chirac à nouveau confrontés aux
affaires il s'agit cette fois du dossier
des emplois présumés fictifs de la ville
de paris à l'époque où il en était le
maire
selon nos confrères du monde une
trentaine d'emplois auraient été occupé
par des proches du chef de l'état sans
contrepartie père didier drogba nergie
blanquette et de très longue haleine
elle passe au crible les centaines de
contrats de chargés de mission passé par
la mairie paris entre 1988 et 1998 dans
leurs locaux de nanterre les policiers
des investigations financières ont
entendu à ce jour 102 personnes qui ont
été à des titres divers
attaché au cabinet du maire le cabinet
de jacques chirac à cueillette en
permanence une centaine de chargé de
mission au contrat plus ou moins long
parmi eux rapporte ce soir le monde des
élus du rpr ou de l'udf de l'époque mais
aussi les épouses d'ancien ministre de
la fonction publique ou des affaires
étrangères le tout jeune fils d'un
magistrat de très haut rang ou encore
des sportifs médaillés olympiques à
l'origine de l'information judiciaire
ouverte il y a deux ans la plainte de
cette écologiste parisien qui suspectent
que le cabinet du maire abrités nombre
d'emplois fictifs
on a une passion le cabinet du maire
était un cabinet de copinage c'est clair
et ce qui est plus grave c'est que même
certains emplois qui étaient des emplois
réels ou la personne travaillait elle
travaillait pas long pour le compte de
la mairie et donc de la communauté
publique la ville de paris mais pour la
partie
il ya effectivement une certaine de
personnes
qui ont été entendus là dedans ils
disent qu'il ya 30 personnes qui soient
réellement effectif sachant qu'il ya
encore environ 300 personnes à
auditionner on peut s'imaginer qu'un
réellement entre 100 ou 150 personnes
qui sont vraiment des emplois fictifs
dans ce dossier pour l'heure aucune mise
en examen ni garde à vue mais une
instruction qui se veut aussi méthodique
exhaustive